police on patrol it's business as usual
in Moscow but this world cup has seen
plenty of changes gatherings aren't
usually allowed here yet people are
celebrating anyway the police keep
everyone safe but they're restraining
themselves and aren't getting involved
we always prepare to help the tourists
you can see that everyone is in a
celebratory mood fans are so
enthusiastic I'm really enjoying this
atmosphere Russians and foreigners
coming together on Red Square a carnival
of Nations so to say while the police
look on connect the police do spot
checks but we don't feel disturbed they
are very polite I've never experienced
and if you like this before
has the World Cup change Russia or will
this fairy tale of openness hospitality
and enthusiasm for the beautiful game
come to an abrupt end everyone's coming
together they're welcoming and friendly
to our visiting friends tourists and
we've really enjoyed it and I see
there's a big difference between Moscow
and the rural areas Moscow has
definitely changed most Russians barely
recognize their own country they marvel
at the changes the country's undergone
the foreigners that state media often
portrayed as a threat actually quite
nice but of course the Kremlin is using
the World Cup for its own agenda it's
pushed through unpopular reforms such as
increasing the pension age at the same
time the government is trying to polish
Russia's image this move with impetus or
you're appointed those in power are
showing their candor they want to
improve Russia's reputation abroad
yes miniature was but we aren't seeing
any real changes to the system we see
live what I'm the probably in previous
World Cups have shown that the host
nations fairy tale ends when the final
whistle is blown but memories always
remain